foreign
[Music]
so I'm working as a scientist like a
research end development scientist at
and sermon so today I'm going to give
you a talk about like introduction to
the Next Generation by analytic
development so uh I would like to focus
like on this title slide with the image
right there so they made itself is kind
of like showing you the complexity of
like from a small molecule to kind of
like going into a recombinant protein
which is like an antibody and then you
go for like a virus which is like a gene
therapy product and then you go for a
cell which is kind of a self-service
product so it's kind of the complexity
that increases from a small molecule
chemical molecule and you jump into a
biologic as the biologic increases you
just have to understand how much complex
these drug products are
so uh I just want to start my
presentation by giving a confidentiality
statement here so most of the uh if the
presentation will be talking about like
the current literature and they may be
forward let me statements in them and
again this is just based on the current
literature that's been published and
again no insurance that like these
expectations or estimates will be
achieved or kind of like will be
accurate in future
so the overview of the talk would be I'm
going to really introduce to the cell
engine W products right now in the
market and then I'm going to talk about
like a drug product life cycle including
how analytical development uh is in
involved or like it's been attached into
this drug product life cycle and then
talk more about like critical quality
attributes and on a general sense and
then I will talk more about critical
quality attributes in cell and gene
therapy uh the stock mostly focuses on
gene therapy products so I will talk
about gene therapy a lot and then I
would talk about different analytical
methods what are the traditional methods
as well as like Advanced methods that
that are being applied to Define these
kind of electrical critical quality
attributes
and sell engine therapy products and I
would give one case study and which is a
article and then I will give final
thoughts of like how uh this crypto
quality attributes can be kind of like
understood or achieved in a gene therapy
product
so as an introduction I want to really
talk about like the cell and Gene W
products and before that I would love to
introduce like uh what is like a gene
therapy and the cell therapy so the one
on the left is kind of more towards the
gene therapy product where we call it as
a Direct Delivery so in which you kind
of have your transcene or a therapeutic
transgene and you kind of embed that
into a kind of a viral genome uh and
which is kind of like uh non-inogenic
viruses so there are different kinds of
viral vectors people use which is kind
of more related to like adrenal viruses
and Associated viruses and lentiviruses
they're also retroviruses people have
been using and once this product has
been produced it's been introduced
intravenously or specifically profism uh
into the region of the area which can be
applied the one on the right is kind of
like a self-tape product so they are
kind of like they can be divided into
two things so South every product can be
a stem cell that can be differentiated
into kind of like the required cell type
and that can be like delivered to a
human
um kind of given to a human for specific
disease or another way people also
create salt every products it's kind of
like you take this viral or non-viral
delivery and deliver the specific plant
seen into uh a specific cell and then
you kind of like manufacture them to
high quality and then uh provide them
to kind of the human and most of the raw
material that's coming from cell therapy
is kind of like when you consider a car
T therapy is the blood itself from a
patient and you kind of like uh ingenate
it in such a way that like you give back
to the patient for uh kind of like
overcome the kind of the disease
so they're kind of like nine products
for cell therapy kimraya uh and escata
are kind of like the ones that have been
approved previously and there are seven
more products that have been approved
and for gene therapy there are kind of
like two products of fruit I'm going to
talk in the next slide what are they and
it's predicted that like they will be
more than 20 to 30 Gene and cell theory
products will be coming through by 2030.
so for the gene therapy approved
Therapies
there are two gene therapy approach
therapies the first one is the luxronum
which is kind of an adenosis or virus II
uh which is primarily focused towards
the inheriter uh retinal diseases and
this has been approved in 2017 and
ideally what the gene delivers is like
an RP RP rp65 chain which has been
delivered into the retinal region of the
eye and it kind of like enhances the
vision
um and the other one the other product
has been approved by FDA in 2019 versus
the zansba which is the av-9 and which
is primarily focused towards the smooth
muscle muscular atrophic disease and in
which you kind of give the S and one
gene which kind of has like an Exon 7 or
8 being deleted and then this is patient
where you kind of give the Exon uh to
make a functional product with a gene
gene therapy uh using HG entropy product
so I would like to talk more on the drug
product life cycle and analytical
development here so
when you look at like a drug product
life cycle from a development stage so
there will be an illicit development and
there will be a late State development
and there'll be a commercial development
and these will be subdivided based on
the product life cycle would be mostly
all the pre-clinical and the phase one
would come under the early State
development whereas the late stage
includes the phase two phase three when
you go to commercial you're like talking
more about the approval and the market
you can see the same life cycle on a
manufacturing scale so most of the time
most of the time a research and
development really finds an ideal lead
candidate and that uh once it's taken
into like a process development where
the engineering GMP is develop where you
come kind of like do all your
engineering runs and that's mostly till
where you complete your phase one phase
two and once you're done you are kind of
like transfer into like clinical GMP
manufacturing which is more towards the
phase three and once you kind of like
get the drug uproot and it really moves
move the drug into the commercial
manufacturing and you're kind of like
have very specific site for this
commercial Manufacturing
and you can look at the same life cycle
from analytical development where
as these drug products have been
developed you always have to have essays
to really Define this drug product so
most of the design Define and evaluate
and optimize of assays really happens
during the research and development
process and once you have like an essay
which is kind of like more defined and
have all your controls ready you kind of
like do your qualification which kind of
stands around that phase one phase two
and once you're moving that into like
phase three that's a moves into phase
three it has to be validated where it's
kind of like more specific regulations
in validation and you kind of like test
all these parameters for validation of
the assay and then once the truck gets
approval into a market it's the essay
itself is moved into commercial uh
manufacturing kind of setup and it's
called like it has a lot more
verification of the essay and robustness
and all other things have been test
so again so this is kind of like just
giving an overview or landscape of like
how things happen
so there are a lot of bottlenecks and
viral Vector manufacturing right now uh
all right
so the key areas where the bottlenecks
really happen is kind of like
which the key areas where r d and kind
of the CMC has to come together to
really meet this commercial stage demand
for this kind of like viral vector and
really produce like a more safety
product and the key areas where r d is
for r d or the CMC focuses a lot with
the current uh state of like cell engine
Derby products is kind of like
the first bottleneck would be the lack
of optimal production system so uh what
it really means is like we don't have
kind of like so all these viral vectors
that are being manufactured is through a
transfection process most of the time
where you have like high grade plasmids
being like transfected into some kind of
a cell line a simple example would be
like a triple transfection of Edna
Associated viruses where you're giving
three plasmids into a hek293 cells to
produce our virus out
so the biggest challenge with this
process is kind of like when you kind of
start dealing with like multiple steps
uh for production uh it's not always
like robust and the variation is very
high uh from lot to lot production and
which kind of like delays uh most of the
production or like you have to do
multiple lots to get like uh enough
amount of product so there are a few few
kind of like uh places where we people
have been working uh so one of the like
area where people have have been putting
more time or investment into is kind of
really developing it producer cell lines
for this like viral vectors uh which
again recombinant protein is a good
example which hotels have been like
modified or engineered for production of
this antibodies and which is kind of
using it produces cell line and they get
a very consistent lot a lot uh
production
so another area where people are
investing a lot is kind of like it takes
a lot of time for producing this
producer cell lines so people are also
investing in synthetic biology to really
understand can we engineer kind of like
these cells in such a way that like
where you can reduce uh where you can
understand the metabolic system of a
cell you can modify in such a way that
like you can enhance the viral uh viral
protein production for in such a way
that like you'll have like more more of
this viral Vector being produced per
scale
so another big challenge is kind of the
product potency where uh you kind of
have like a product that's been produced
for a specific lot and it's not very
consistent and it may be where uh you
have a high requirement where you're not
really achieving that uh in that case
you are kind of like consistently
pulling lots to create that high amount
of those uh so again that this is still
like the categorization of the potenti
assays have to be like worked out and
that's where the field is also working
on and another area is kind of like the
non-adaptable use of this Upstream
bioprocessing so most of the time as the
demand is so high most of the companies
are like most of the time we kind of
like work with kind of transaction model
and carry out the whole engineering run
but once it's been transferred into a
kind of like the initial commercial or
kind of like the phase three
Manufacturing
you kind of have to have a more robust
process and as the scale is like it
should be scalable so what are what are
whatever the offstream bioprocessors
right now are not really scalable that's
a big challenge or bottleneck another
area is kind of like the absence of very
suitable analytics and properly defined
critical quality attributes for SL and
the gene therapy product so this is kind
of like uh and a like an important area
where uh the physical quality attributes
are not really defined but the they are
like Investments happening in such a way
to really Define these so I'm going to
talk more about the critical quality
attributes
the looking a critical quality attribute
from an FDA guidance point of view so a
critical a critical quality attribute uh
can be defined as a quality attribute
that should have an appropriate range uh
it should be a specific limit for it and
or the distribution in such a way that
like it will ensure the product
qualities somehow uh very critical we
Define the quality of the product
so
like in a general scale like any general
guidance like how are these critical
quality attributes being defined when
you consider like a small molecule word
or like a recombinant protein world so
once you have like a lead candidate and
you kind of like want to really
understand uh a critical quality
attribute for that lead candidate so
what normally uh people start with is
kind of like they kind of start with a
quality Target product profile so it
really taken the drug product and really
understanding oh what's the mechanism of
action of this drug product and how what
is the efficacy and safety limited
really understanding that and what's the
dosage form is it really given like in a
liquid form or any other different form
and route of administration is it like
taken given like uh intravenously or
intramuscularly uh once uh all these are
defined and they really come together
and fit into a regulatory requirements
once they start really taking the
product and they'll start looking at the
Quality attributes so these quality
attributes are really defined by two
important factors one factor is called
severity and the other factor is called
likelihood
so severity is kind of like depends on
the safety and efficacy of the product
so
the severity kind of takes into account
the kind of like when I say safety is
this drug product safe enough to give to
like a human that's the first question
they'll be asking and when they talk
about like efficacy is this drug product
efficacy is enough like whatever product
that's been produced has good amount of
potent product that's been able to
create that efficacy
and they also look at the likelihood so
the likelihood is defined based on like
what is the chance this drug product can
actually cause a adverse event
so they kind of give scores based on
that one and they calculate a casualty
score using the severity and the
likelihood and once they give
a casualty score for all these quality
attributes they kind of rank them and
identify the ones that are kind of like
a particularly specific quality
attributes and they kind of Define more
like a control strategy around it really
understand Deep dive into these quality
attributes or they really defining the
product as during a process so when I
say process it can be a kind of like a
manufacturing process uh it can be a
pretty clinical study or it can be a
clinical study so
as they get all the information they
start doing kind of a risk assessment
and for the risk assessment it's kind of
a repetitive process to really
understand uh these quality attributes
and then they finalize like this
critical quality attribute
identification
so
this is kind of a regular process that
happens for small molecule as well as
the recombinant protein so but based on
some of the initial data the field for
cell and gene therapy actually provided
a
critical quality attributes uh
definition
so
the political quality attributes for
cell and Gene are primarily taken from
the recombinant protein world and been
applied into cell and gene therapy
products so
this this table actually defines kind of
like few elements for a critical quality
attribute so one is kind of an attribute
class
so which is kind of like when you take a
drug product it should have some
physical identity it has to have a
purity safety potency and quality
so for a slng enthalpy product we kind
of use different methods to Define these
attribute class
and each class will have a quality
attribute so if I consider identity if I
take a gene therapy product and if I'm
using a genomic method or a proteomic
method I should be able to give a
quality attribute a specific attribute
it would be if I'm using an a new
Associated virus I should be able to
give using my methods this is so this is
the transcene which is very specific and
this is the phenotype which will be the
serotype of the specific uh virus it may
be like at no Associated Wireless two
nine and the genotype will give you the
specific transient you want to deliver
so this is kind of like a quality
attribute so
we also have guidance for this from FDA
again these guidances are all still from
the recombinant protein world and then
applied to cell engine therapy so as we
look at this table so there are five
different attributes and when you look
at these test methods there are multiple
analytical methods have been applied to
achieve a attribute class
so
as you look at like uh Purity and Purity
uh it's primarily focused around the
product and process impurities where you
kind of understand oh how is your viral
Vector aggregation happening or their
other uh product impurities that are
coming with the product itself so these
are like uh one another example so
we can also look into kind of like each
attribute class and different methods
analytical methods that have been
traditionally applied and as we want to
understand the Next Generation by
analytics here uh I would give like an
uh kind of like an overview of like how
these different class attributes have
been identified using a traditional
method and then Advanced method
so the first attribute class we can look
at is potency so which is kind of like a
very important attribute class for viral
vectors and cellular free products so
potency actually defines the uh kind of
like the efficacy of the product so we
are kind of uh an example would be a
viral titer for viral vectors we can
talk about so a viral Vector of a can be
like in traditional method normally
people use is kind of like a
quantitative PCR So In traditional
method the quantitative PCR uh is kind
of a like some of the drawbacks one of
the drawback would be it's like Road low
reproducibility the reason why is kind
of like you're always in need of a
qualified standard and the standard
itself uh manufacturing the standard
itself can create that reproducibility
issue
so the second would be people have used
on a pro protein technology is the
analyzer so the Eliza is kind of like uh
more like a time consuming and it has a
lot of essay variability and you ideally
have to design specific essays for every
serotype dependent so you have to have
like analyzer for aav2 or av-9 you use
it's very specific and you have to
really uh optimize it to your specific
serotype it's all the time consuming
so
as the cell and Gene inter results are
complex the people have identified like
applying Advanced methods would be a
kind of like an orthogonal way of really
applying uh Advanced methods would be
ideal to Define these products better so
people have been using traditional
methods and now people are like slowly
moving into this Advanced methods and
for genomics people started to use the
digital PCR the reason why it's like
more sense to um so you can have like a
low high range on the lower end where
you can identify like very low copy
numbers and another thing is like it's
an absolute so you really don't need a
polypat standard for that
um when you want to use a proteomic
method people have started using this
size execution hplc methods uh the only
reason is kind of like height report you
can run like multiple samples and again
based on it's kind of like a more
sensitive and like a low variability
it's like very low because like it uh
it's it's based on like you read the
Peaks you have control so it's kind of
like
um so these methods have been started to
apply for this initial potency essays to
Define uh kind of like more of this
quality attributes
so
the next uh quality attribute we can
look at is the Purity so when I say
Purity it's kind of morally focusing
towards the impurities uh and the purity
of the drug product so the intuities can
come from the process as well as the
product impurities
so the traditional methods people have
been used using previously and still
people use these traditional methods
it's kind of like uh one is like the SDS
page uh which is kind of like a very low
sensor and like you need a large sample
requirement and allies as I talked it's
like more time consuming and assay
variable is very high and there's
another method where people also use is
the capillary
capillary ultraforosis which is kind of
using a UV sensor uh which is again has
that low sensitivity and
to kind of like Advanced and identify
Purity so the the the field itself had
started using these Advanced methods uh
one is to kind of for the genomics
people have started using the next and
sequencing where which is kind of like
highly characterizable and highly
sensitive
and
the other one is the mass spectroscopy
where you have like a hard you can have
a high throughput and highly sensitive
and like you get a huge amount of data
about your truck product uh from Mass
spectroscopy uh another like a quick
method people have started using the
capital rail proposals with the uh kind
of like the
fluorescence fluorescence detector so
where the flow sense detector itself
will give like a high sensitivity and a
small sample volume is required to
really achieve uh identify like kind of
the quality attribute as a purity from
this method
so
the other quality attribute for cell
engine is kind of the identity which is
kind of like really saying uh am I
really
the producing the right product here
so for that the traditional methods are
kind of like Western blot and the
capillary Ultra process and Western blot
itself is like has low sensitivity you
have to have like a lot sample volume
you have to have a specific uh
concentration to really identify uh your
viral vector and as like an advanced
method you have like uh people started
to use like Mass spectroscopy so it will
give you like a more better
characterization information and it will
give you like more about like how is
this product itself like what what is
the modifications does the product have
as this being produced in mammalian
cells these viral vectors are there any
post translation modifications happening
and will give you like a lot more
information
uh and also the capital forces with the
fluorescence director also is kind of
like very quick and gives you more uh
kind of like requests more information
so
the
the other quality attribute would be the
drug qualities uh product quality in
which where we are kind of like looking
at uh it's kind of like oh you have a
DOT product final quality or is it you
purified the whole viral Vector product
or drug product
what do we have in there is there like
really important product or do we have
like you know any non-specific uh drug
product being available so
for the traditional methods people have
used is to really
kind of like once you I didn't want to
really get a very pure product people
have you started people use interest on
others if the analytical Ultra
centrifugation uh which is kind of very
low sensitivity and it has it requires
really large volume
um and another simple kind of like a
traditional method is the optical
density which is kind of using the 260
by 2
uh or like 260 for DNA and 280 for
protein and really getting like an
understanding of like the product
quality again it's it's kind of like a
low sensitive and kind of like again
requires a larger volume if you're using
required to it actually
so the more advanced methods with the
product quality because like product
quality has become like a more uh
it's kind of like is that you're really
looking at the final product that goes
into like a free clinical study or a
clinical study people have put more
effort on really understanding the broad
quality here and again the advancement
that people started to apply uh is the
anion uh kind of like the anion exchange
now chromatography with hplc so which
kind of gives you uh very specific uh
kind of like
um sorting uh the sample out and really
high throughput and highly sensitive uh
and kind of like use your better
categorization and the other one people
saw like the literature State
Illustrated or like most of the groups
started to use is kind of this multiple
detector uh detectors attaching to hplc
so the kind of like using different
detectors on hplc to really Define this
product quality
so it really gives like more information
on an orthogonal way it gives you
accurate and robust information and it
also measures like multiple physical
attributes at the same time and it's
also highly sensitive so I think like as
the field evolves I think this is where
the field will be evolving more as
because these are complex products you
really have to identify like a number of
things uh around the drug product so
maybe this detector application will be
like
and will be seen more so on the same
lines I can actually give you a one case
study actually
so
in this study from gangans
what they did was kind of like they kind
of used a multiple mortar hplc study to
really identify in process monitoring so
they've been producing like a V
production and they're purifying the aav
so there are multiple steps in the
process so they want to use this hplc to
really use kind of like okay a normal
hvlc comes with a UV detector they want
to add like this in
kind of the instance
a kind of the light scattering eccentric
and the insta in instrumentic
fluorescence detectors and then they
want to really identify is are they able
to really give them enough information
about the drug product about the Purity
and all other critical attributes
so
the key takeaways was kind of like when
they used like an in intrinsic uh
fluorescence they were able to really
detect like uh the sensitivity of Av
detection was more compared to UV uh
when they kind of use kind of a light
scattering uh they were able to really
identify AV capsid in complex samples so
uh as the sample is being purified it
starts with this cellular lysate and you
kind of like slowly reduce the cellular
lysate and get your drug product out and
that's what they're claiming like the
light scattering was able to really
identify even in a complex samples
and the other when they use like an
extrinsic fluorescence uh they were able
to really track uh all this x the DNA
from the whole cell uh and they were
able to really show them like when you
use all these kind of like uh monitoring
uh systems at one time the complex
samples like uh like gene therapy
samples were able to be clearly uh
provide good answers about the product
so this
the kind of like what this uh uh graph
actually shows the chromatogram show
here
it's kind of like they were showing data
kind of with the UV where you look at
like the kind of show like it's only
like 18 of like uh empty capsids when
they read the same sample with the light
scattering uh kind of like a light
scattering
uh diode like and what they found was
it's like around 24 percent of empty cap
sets and when they use an interesting uh
fluorescence they were able to show like
around like the 26 percent uh so what
they want to really explain is kind of
like the UV detector which traditionally
used uh is kind of like
more kind of like
underestimating
uh it's just because like uh the reason
why it's like UV just uses like
tryptophan uh to give the reading out so
there's a high possibility that like it
it can be or uh underestimated sometimes
so
and that's what they claim like you know
once they start using multiple
kind of like the monitor sensors they
were able to really Define in a more
clear way
so another again the article I just took
like very few figures there like more
data in this article but like this just
an example where uh they did an
experiment where they kind of like took
the
cellular lysate and applied like protein
SK so they're trying to reduce like all
the histone and all the protein on the
background uh when so they kind of
couple the UV with the extrinsic
fluorescence using the Pico green so
Pico green specifically Central
collecting dye
goes and really interacts with the DNA
so when you have like a double standard
DNA this die can really sit in the
double standard DNA so using an UV what
they're showing is like uh the UV itself
is not able to pick any chromatin uh in
the chromatogram the first chromatogram
and when they add like a protein SK
treatment for one hour and 24 hours
what they're showing is the green is
kind of the Pico green so the Pico green
completely shows it's become High
sensitive and really picks all the
plasmid and the DNA that's present in
the sample where it clearly showing all
the protein is being chewed off by the
protein SK but when you look at the UV
which is the blue kind of like the
protein and the kind of the red is kind
of layer your DNA the UV is not so
sensitive enough to really pick enough
amount of DNA so yeah so it's clearly
showing that like once you kind of have
multiple
uh kind of like uh monitoring systems
it's it clearly shows like
um it's becoming more sense to and
accurate for for a complex product like
a gene therapy product
and I I'm I speculate like these these
kind of studies will happen more and
really will be like this is this is
where the Next Generation paralytics for
cell and Gene will be like moving into
so
so
as I said like we talked a lot about
like critical quality attributes uh
there are multiple challenges to apply
traditional application of critical
quality attributes for cell and gene
therapy products so the schema I showed
you before
it's kind of been defined for small
small molecule and recombinant protein
and people have applied that schema and
really able to were able to identify the
critical quality attributes easily for
uh for other products but the challenges
that can come for this
7g interview product when you're trying
to identify this critical quality
attributes will be like the first
challenge would be because the products
there are a lot of products and research
and development and very few products
have been approved by market and lot has
been in clinical trials it's like very
limited knowledge uh we just have very
limited Knowledge from the clinical
point of view to really identify this
critical quality attributes and risk
assessments
and
again the batch production tends to be
limited as I said like there's a lot of
best to bat variation when you produce
these so one match one batch may be very
important the other batch may be not
potent so these are like a lot of
um the variability itself it's a
limitation to really identify the steel
quality attribute
uh and there is not much of similar
products to really accumulate enough of
like this risk assessment data from
clinical trials to really show that like
okay
uh this is a product which may be
similar I can really identify critical
derivative a simple example would be you
have an antibody and you create a
biosimilar so you have like data from
clinicals on antibody and we create a
biosimilar you kind of like take the
data and really compare oh what can be
the address events that are coming in as
a simple example I can tell
and the other would be the product
development knowledge is very limited
it's it's just like we are still
understanding how
how are these produced and what's the
best way to get the right EA of and uh
okay okay as I said the knowledge is
limited is based on like how the
production manufacturing is still not
really up to the scale as we expected
so
placing the same schema
how can we develop like a critical
quality attribute identification in gene
therapy
so
I I I took the same schema that's been
applied uh to like a recombinant protein
so once you define the quality Target
product profile
so you kind of come and Define your
quality attributes so the quality
attributes are actually defined in the
table Below based on the product related
and the process related
so normally so there are different
models people apply and for gene therapy
product we should go with the
preliminary Hazard model the reason why
we go with this model to identify
critical quality attributes
it's kind of like
the preliminary Hazard model actually
takes into consideration only uh the
knowledge that's been available on the
product limited knowledge that's
available on the product and most of the
IHC guidelines when you want to identify
critical quality attributes requests to
get data from clinical trials for the
risk assessment and then apply for the
quality attributes and Define the
critical quality attributes so as we
don't have enough of uh kind of like
scientific literature or the data so the
preliminary Hazard model takes into
consultation
that aspect and then we can apply that
model to really identify our critical
quality attributes
so
yeah so again the schema is the same
schema and kind of like the product and
the process related uh quality
attributes and we start really uh The
Next Step would be really taking each of
these uh attributes and calculating kind
of your severity score and the
likelihood scores and then you kind of
come up with the criticalities uh
if you come up with the
criticality score and then you kind of
rank them and then you go apply uh to
the process and really Define your
critical quality attribute and once you
have your identified critical called
attribute then you start doing you use
your design space quality by Design and
apply to that
and
so
I have some of the references for the
talk uh which kind of like uh have
again these are kind of like more
related to like analytical methods and
process and Drug categorization and
again new uh the latest drug dealer bio
analytical process has been applied
um yeah
and thank you very much for the time